e ele sabe que fica na Fazenda gritam
gente pensa que a gente tá você tá
andando de noite tá fazendo escolhas
sempre um monte de sapo
sapo gente boa moço sapo inseto e geral
eu não gostei os bons o mosquito é um
lixo abelha gente boa porque abelha
chique mosca come bosta abelha toma Coca
Abreu trajeto aqui se abre assim um
agora eu tinha e abelha tão insistente
pela qual que aquela roda tanto volta
tanto tanto copo da gente a gente
desiste a pessoa que não que a gente
perde o refrigerante para abelha agora
mosquito não não serve morra todos hoje
se puder agora a formiga a formiga não
sei o que é que eu sinto pela formiga da
família me traz o sentimento de
bipolaridade que a família trai a
confiança da gente a formiga tá andando
a gente a gente acha bonitinha olha
bonitinha formiga e olha caminhando ela
morre filha da [ __ ] pau no cu me mordeu
cara isso é triste é uma mala ela alguns
segundos atrás de mordeu matei formiga é
massa que a formiga em